this is evan langer reading for writer
kevin kenizevek mario golf super rush
will be available later this month on
nintendo switch
but before launch we got a chance to see
more of the game during a virtual
preview event and in this video we'll be
discussing our hands-off impressions
if you like this video and want to see
more mario golf super rush coverage
including our review then consider
subscribing to gamespot
nice huh nearly three years to date
after mario and friends hit the courts
in mario tennis aces the plumber is
returning in mario golf super rush the
latest entry in nintendo's long-running
sports series
as it did with the aforementioned aces
developer camelot has taken the familiar
mario golf gameplay and livened it up
with more action
making super rush an even snappier take
on the sport than previous installments
the headlining new addition in this
installment is speedgolf a hectic new
mode in which you and three other
golfers compete to sink the ball
the fastest unlike during a standard
round of golf each player takes their
shots simultaneously and you must
manually run to your ball after you've
hit it making this mode a mad dash to
the green
the ultimate aim of speed golf is to
clear every hole in the fastest time
each shot you take adds 30 seconds to
your timer which is where precision
comes into play
you can feasibly sync your ball before
the other players by hitting it as
quickly as possible but if you take too
many shots you'll end up with a slower
overall time so you'll need to strike a
balance between speed
and careful play to prevail on route to
your ball you'll be able to unleash a
special dash which will knock down any
opponents you barrel over costing them
coins and more precisely
time each of the game's 16 characters
boasts their own signature special dash
yoshi for instance roll atop a giant egg
when a special dash is activated
as in previous games every character
also has their own special shots which
can be employed to interrupt other
players
these elements come together to make
speed golf a clever frenetic take on the
sport and it looks like it'll be the
highlight of the package
this isn't the only major change camelot
has implemented however the studio has
also tweaked other aspects of the
gameplay to improve the overall
experience
in the standard golf mode you'll now be
able to choose between take turns
and an all at once option for
multiplayer sessions the former is the
more traditional way to play with each
player alternating turns while the
ladder lets everyone tee off
simultaneously
the object is still to sink the ball in
the fewest shots possible so your time
won't affect your score as it does in
speed golf but this option looks like
it'll make rounds much
faster each mode also gives you the
option to play 3 6
9 or the full 18 holes of a course and
the game features an extensive glossary
explaining golf terminology and controls
for newer players
the other major addition in mario golf
super rush is golf adventure
a light rpg-like story mode in which you
guide your me characters on a journey to
become a pro golfer
as part of your adventure you'll need to
talk to coaches around the various clubs
you visit to learn more about different
golfing techniques and complete lessons
as you progress your meat will level up
which in turn will improve your stats
coins you earn during your adventure can
also be used to purchase new outfits and
other gear
like pieces of equipment and rpgs the
gear will improve your stats when
equipped and you'll also be able to use
your powered up me in other modes
much like the adventure mode in mario
tennis aces golf adventure serves as a
good way to acclimate players to the
game's controls and the general rules of
golf
but there's also a story running through
the mode revolving around wario and
waluigi search for a treasure
while pursuing the pair you'll also
encounter several boss battles
the first pits you against a knight that
launches lightning bolts you'll need to
avoid and deflect the knight's attacks
with golf swings to topple the boss
between the frantic new speed golf mode
and the other tweaks camelot has made
mario golf super rush is shaping up to
be another enjoyable entry in the
golfing series
thanks for watching if you like this
video then consider clicking the like
button and let us know in the comments
what future mario golf super rush videos
you'd like to see
for all things mario stay tuned to game
[Music]
spot
you